[Music]
tom is with us in jacksonville florida
hey tom what's up
hey what's going on
hey man we're gonna make it how can we
help
hey so i got kind of a scriptural
question for you and then then a
follow-up about uh what i should do
about it
so i took a job selling solar panels in
in in florida
and my original plan
was to you know develop my sales skills
and earn money at the job while i'm
building my own business on the side
and i've been doing it for a few weeks
and what i've started to realize is
i'm not really selling solar panels as
much as i'm selling the loans the
financing for them
and this is kind of making me want to
reevaluate
uh
what i'm doing with the
with the job so
i'll explain how the company
uh
frames the financing because i want to
hear your opinion on that um oh i know
and then okay
yeah okay so and then and then
and then i want to know like you know if
you think i should just keep it moving
and focus on building my business
full-time instead of you know doing this
so
and yeah you might already know this but
i'll just i'll just run through it real
quick so that that's okay you don't you
don't need to run through it they
basically sell it for
the savings
on the electric bill due to having solar
panels will pay your payments
and we endorse uh solar panel companies
in several cities but we do never
endorse them
doing financing and we never endorse
anyone doing financing because we don't
believe in debt and that's an obvious
thing but that that doesn't necessarily
affect you that's us
and uh but it's a standard thing in that
business they use the savings to pay the
payments is the sales pitch and then
they usually sell the paper and
sometimes they make a cajillion dollars
on the paper when they sell it as well
depending on the company and how jacked
up the financing situation is ken how do
you think you address this from an
ethical standpoint
i think from an ethical standpoint i
don't think you're doing anything
ethically wrong or legally wrong but it
isn't and clear uh it's it's a clear
violation in your mind of your values of
what you believe in and that is okay but
i think we've got to take we have to
separate what you disagree with versus
you doing something wrong and so i would
quickly try to look for another sales
job but i'd stay where i am until i can
replace
my
day-to-day income here's why you're
probably not able to pay your bills with
your side hustle is that true or false
yeah currently no yeah so you got to
look at this as a math situation so when
you can get to the point where you can
pay
a large portion of what you're making
now at least to take care of your basic
needs then you're ready to go full time
until then you're not so you're not
doing anything ethically wrong i'd start
looking for another sales job that will
allow you to make the money you're
making now maybe even more which will
continue to allow continue to give you
stability to allow you to grow the side
business but you're not
you're not breaking the law
therefore this isn't an ethical thing
this is a values thing and don't make
any crazy jumps nothing for you to be
ashamed of or feel guilty of you've seen
the light take your time find something
replace it move on yeah it you know
there's a lot of things you can sell
that you don't have to sell through
financing
lots and lots of things uh that it's
optional
you know that um not everybody that buys
a car finances it not everybody that
buys a solar panel's finances here for
that matter and i'm a big believer in
solar panels uh in certain situations
uh the the current technology is far
superior to what it was even a decade
ago
and so the break-even analysis on it is
real but i would pay cash for them or i
wouldn't buy them but i say that about
everything there's nothing i would pay i
would buy that i wouldn't pay cash for
um if it's valid or not valid whatever
it is i mean whether it's just a stupid
luxury item or whether something's gonna
actually break even on it
so that's the way i view it uh and so it
but if this company is jacked up and you
know like you're disobeying
your superior if you don't cram
financing down their throat and you're
uncomfortable doing that then it's time
to look for something else to sell until
you get your side gig moving
because you're not in alignment with
them and you're not going to be
comfortable doing it so hey man thanks
for the call you know i'll tell you
where else i ran into that was the
underwear place victoria's secret
they
she said if they don't uh if they don't
sell if they're working the floor a
salesperson and they don't sell
a certain number of credit cards a day
get certain number of applications a day
for the victoria's secret credit card
they get fired oh wow yeah so i mean
it's nothing about there's nothing about
selling the small underwear it's about
selling credit that's right well that's
happening in a lot there was no there
was no quota on amount of underwear sold
no just the financing card you know just
just whether or not you got the
victoria's secret card yeah and so best
buy is about the same way oh big time
best buy is a horrid
mess
you can get really good buys in best buy
on things if you just pay for them but
they make because they don't have a lot
of margin no they don't make a lot of
money on tv those tvs are not a bad buy
at all
you'd be hard-pressed to beat their
prices you can find you can beat them
that's true but uh good good prices but
the uh um
but they make all their money on
extended warranties and on financing and
the stupid best buy credit card my god
they will put an extended warranty on a
number two pencil over there yeah i mean
i never saw anything like it they're
just um it's the same place that rooms
that goes
it's just walking you can't even get out
through the register no you've got a 19
year old hanging around your ankles
until you sign the extended warranty you
know it's like it's ridiculous it's true
and um
just but but what amounts to is is they
they got sideways when they realized
they could make more money on the
issuing of credit than they could on the
sale of solar panels they got sideways
when they realized they could make more
money on the issuing of credit than they
could the sale of televisions or more
money on the extended warranties than
they could the actual television that's
correct and so and card you know use car
dealers man somebody's used car
warranties are unfreaking believable
rip-offs so you've just gotta you know
you you cannot be successful at
something when you feel like you're not
doing right for the customer yep long
term you you can't look at yourself in
the mirror and go i i wouldn't do this
to my brother i wouldn't do this to my
mother i wouldn't do this to my best
friend then you don't need to be doing
it that's correct but don't make a bad
financial decision meaning leave a job
without something to walk into because
you feel bad you're a good person you're
not doing anything illegal be smart yeah
dave here's something i got to ask you
about because i'm you're absolutely
right
about you know these companies like best
buy they understand people are just they
are so needy for stuff that they're in
the finance business i got to ask you
this i saw a headline over the weekend
that there are huge swaths of the
american public that are paying
several thousand dollars above msrp for
a car oh yeah and i just don't
understand why people feel like they've
got to have a car that bad a brand new
car
uh
sales yeah i mean it's it's marketing
and sales yeah i mean and it's just it's
uh scarcity and urgency you know i i was
talking about that day rachel was making
fun of me because we had a guy call in
want to buy a new car and i still
wouldn't go with it because he said he
could get a sticker and the hot cars are
going for more than a sticker so he
thinks it's a bargain that's a bargain
yeah so
but car used cars are going up right
well you think this is a can you think
this is a trend that's going to continue
for 10 years come on man it's not going
to but i have a good friend that went to
look at a hundred thousand dollar
vehicle sticker on is 107
and uh the guy told him you know he said
okay so
you know i'm gonna bite it in voice and
he goes uh no these cars are sticker
full sticker
let me pay msrp
he goes yeah he goes if you go to the
other dealership across town for this
hundred thousand dollar car it's a 20
000 oversticker oh yeah he goes we're
the good guys we're selling it at
sticker
and i'm like oh
i
think i'll sit this one out boys and
girls
and you know that's what's interesting
the power of the people if people would
realize if you would just say no to your
urge and you stop doing this the car
dealers would have to drop the price
it's all about demand yeah the shortage
of supply and demand and that's it's
like that's why it's driven all this
stuff up artificially and it's going to
come right back down
on some of this you know lumber
cars you have to worry about those
they're going gonna come back down